heute bei wissel macht einen politischen
aschermittwoch der spd untersuchen wir
woher kommt der hype um martin schulz
martin schulz ein
woran liegt es dass junge menschen sich
wieder für ihre cd interessieren
das wird einfach eine ausstrahlung die
der unglaublich ruhig durch dir mal den
gabriel sein gesicht das ist ja nicht
normal aber der schulter jung
sympathisch aber eine ausstattung ist er
unglaublich dass der guardian hat texas
weiß ja sozusagen
ich freue mich dass die leute werden
jährlich glücklich vielleicht verliebt
auch ein verlief nicht bewährte
betrieben in london wo seine
ausstrahlung hoffte die jesus war die
jesus für die spd der malerischen
[Musik]
ratlos auch in fotos und bayern
übernehmen
erst machte bundeskanzler und wenn er
dann noch erhört und wichtiges amt will
dann kann er sich um den spd vorsitz in
bayern bewerben aber erste positive
arroganz sehr beliebt macht genau man
hat auch schon mal schlecht gemacht
damals mit unseren nochmal spd politiker
vergesse ich auch immer direkt er früher
mal kandidat war ich einfach man
eigentlich aber ging dann für sie was
glauben sie woran nicht mehr martin
schulz hat martin schulz ist authentisch
wirklich authentisch also authentisch
ich glaube das ist die authentizität
seiner persönlichkeit weil aufgang von
unten kommt wenn man sich mit der spd
aufnehmen können weil die themen kern
zählen von martin schulz nennen etwa
allmählich abitur staub oder eine frage
wurde ich auch aber der falsche ist
vorbei gibt halt keine kernthesen kannst
du mal die zehn kernthesen von martin
schult nennen
nur eines sagen viel anfangen
aber soziale themen wieder stark in den
vordergrund gestellt worden und auch
eine mögliche korrekt war das mache
jetzt weder immer voller wahl
als der pflicht gemacht das hat er auch
sein traditionelles linke war ja
eingeläutet und dann klappt es am ende
geworden
thomas schiff aufgespürt worden
die haben sie hier in bayern überhaupt
schon dieser spd erfahren
die kennen die spd schon sehr lange in
bayern registriert
ist das überhaupt erlaubt ihr
persönliche hilfe erlauf die bayern
wissen sie man für doch internet fündig
werden niemand jeder weiß dass hier für
den beim tippen sie auch ganz gut mit
dem thema aber damals keine chance
ich wache nicht mehr so wie die ganze
welt ist in bewegung und die partei
besser ist wirklich wahr wo es um
beratung dabei das so ist es
es gibt nie eine welt wo immer voller
besteht nicht das gibt es sich für
niemanden auch im privaten leben nicht
ich habe heute versuchte eine
wissenschaftliche erklärung für das
phänomen martin schulz
doch letztendlich muss man sagen gibt
keine erklärung von eilig das ganze nur
einen einzigen schloss martin schulz und
100 das wunder von höheren lohn und
damit pro kind zu welt
[Applaus]